so let's uh you you wanna talk about
afghanistan
uh we can talk about afghanistan donald
trump in his second term agenda said he
wants to
put an end to these endless wars and
he's already tried to bring our troops
back and for me
that's why i supported tulsi gabbard
earlier now i think the democrats
they've got nothing to offer
i'm not convinced joe biden would would
do anything in this capacity i'm curious
what your thoughts on that is would you
do you support the president in terms of
getting our troops out of iraq and
afghanistan that that's a complicated
question
um i think right now i'm at the point
where we need to bring our people home
but allow me to answer with context
it's a tough decision it's it's a
conundrum for a litany of reasons
we went over there to afghanistan our
mission was to find bin laden close with
and destroy the enemy but part of what
we did was take care of the people we
made them a promise
and we saw the afghan people come out of
the woodwork
to fight for their freedom i mean little
kids little boys come on the base work
on our base during the day with their
dads
little kids go to school girls schools
that we built we built
wells in villages and we brought food
and water and
taught little girls how to read and
little boys how to we talked to trades i
mean a lot of what we did was
humanitarian work over there
and you know afghan patriots came out of
the woodwork to fight for the freedom of
their country
and i and i realize and i know and you
need to trust me on this
we pull out of that country in three
months every one of them people are
hanging by
hanging by a light post i guarantee it
every man woman and child that supported
americans in that country is dead in
three months
wow and that scares the crap out of me
and it makes me wonder you know
do we look it's complicated right like
our promise
as as the americans our promise should
mean something to our allies
so i recognize that okay uh
so a humanitarian crisis could ensue in
afghanistan if we pull out
right on the other side is that as a
commander-in-chief we have a duty and
obligation
to america's sons and daughters who suit
up and go over there and go to war and
risk their life for everything
and my issue with the afghan war right
now
is that if you asked you went over there
right now and we picked up this podcast
and we just interviewed
you know 10 different american privates
from different units that have never
communicated together
ever what's the what's your mission
right now you'd get a different answer
from all of them
and that's a real problem wow because
when you don't know and understand what
the mission is
you don't understand what the mission is
when you're out there beyond the wire
you're hesitant and those seconds
hesitation can be the difference between
life and death and so
we have a duty and obligation to make
sure that our people know what the
mission is
know what the end state is uh you know
end state operations know what victory
looks like if
if it can be clearly defined and right
now i don't think we have that
so what i would propose in afghanistan
is
you can do more in that country with far
less
now in 2006 we had one brigade like
roughly
eight plus thousand war fighters right
now supported by by
more but for all of what they call rc
east and afghanistan regional command
east that's the
that's the entire border region and
we took the fight to the enemy in a way
in 2006 to where in 2007 we were getting
intelligence from the front that
the pakistani taliban were broken al
qaeda was decimated hakamatir
haqqani network groups uh terrorist
islamic factions on the border they were
broken their will to fight was done we
were just killing too many of their sons
they just didn't want to commit their
sons to the fight that was it
and look this might sound harsh but
you kill the enemy you secure the people
you know the people of afghanistan were
starting to enjoy a level of peace and
prosperity that they never thought
possible in their country
and then pre then then president obama
was elected uh well even you know maybe
even truthfully just before that
uh when president bush was still
president we shifted our strategy from
counter terror which was
finding the bad guys and killing them to
counter insurgency
which is let's get u.s soldiers in every
village to make sure that they can build
a rapport with the people
and so we started building combat
outposts and you see uh
you know you've seen the movie the
outpost and we we put them in
uh we built the very first combat
outpost in a place called combat outpost
margaux which is right on the border in
a horrible location
horrible tactical location hills
surrounding a hill surrounding it
and at the tail end of our deployment
that base was attacked by over 300 enemy
fighters now we knew that they were
coming we caught them and we ended up
killing every single one of them
but every year after that every single
year after that an american combat
outpost was attacked
and nearly overrun in some cases they
were overrun
when we shifted our strategy from
counter-terror to counter-insurgency we
lost the initiative in afghanistan
because we spread what we call we spread
our combat power out too thinly on the
border
so most of these combat outposts yes
they were among the villagers but we
didn't have the manpower to
both occupy the bases and patrol
offensively
so we just what does that mean we just
sat there right occupied the bases and
just got attacked
and because of that the enemy was able
to penetrate
from pakistan into the heart of
afghanistan now the enemy's all over
and so i afghanistan's a tough situation
now now
where do i fall so so what would i do i
i would
shift our mission set right now from
counter insurgency which i think this
president has already done
to counter terror and make sure that
we're going after the worst of the worst
right let's keep them guessing let's
keep the enemy guessing let's make
never feel comfortable make them move
from one cave to the next right
why because the whole reason we went in
there was to keep that country from
becoming a petri dish for terrorists
from which they can
launch attacks against the united states
or any one of our allies so
you can do that with you know a couple
of special forces teams the seal team
delta you've got a ranger battalion or
maybe a couple infantry battalions for
force protection what that means is like
they're just they'll discard the base or
they'll do outer cordons for kinetic
strikes
and when you do that you afford the
afghan government the ability to
project strength and you know safely
secure
and govern its people and so you can do
that with a lot less money
and the strategy would be a lot more
effective and it's kind of the middle of
the road right
we pull all our troops out which would
be a humanitarian crisis
we leave all our troops in the mission
is muddied we don't really
we don't really have the initiative it's
a mess yeah
we keep a small group there to target
the worst of the worst we allow the
afghan government to extend its reach
and while maybe maybe we help the afghan
national army a little bit while we're
there to help them safely and help them
secure their people as well
in in in iraq i think we only have like
what 500 yeah but we are our footprint
in iraq is far smaller although i do
think we've got a plussed up presence of
special forces troops there
yeah what do you what do you think about
you know we've got all these military
bases all over the place
particularly in europe donald trump was
threatening to pull our troops out of
germany
you know you just what's your general i
want to hear from somebody who's
actually got experience
you know i was in germany uh it's
amazing amazing duty assignment
and my experience with the german people
is they loved
they loved the americans they liked that
we were there um well are they paying
their fair share
for the gdp for our well
well yeah well i mean look let's let's
be i mean the
american bases in germany are a
tremendous economic boost for that
country
uh but the german people i think also
appreciate the fact that we're there
for them and um
you know we've had a long-standing
relationship with germany they're one of
our main allies in the region uh but
as our president would say they're not
certainly not paying their fair share
yeah and so i've i have less of an issue
with
you know the u.s having military bases
in
allied countries particularly germany or
whatever
if they're not paying and we're
providing security i do think it's
particularly funny
when it comes to a lot of these
left-wing arguments about socialism
the first thing is they think european
countries are socialists when they're
not they're just welfare states with you
know capitalist economy
but they also don't realize that for
instance sweden is one i believe
uh one of the largest weapons exporters
per capita so they make a ton of money
shipping out weapons they can use that
to pay for social benefits
and then you have many of these european
nations which have security
provided for or at least bolstered by
u.s forces and
they're not paying their their their
targeted gdp into it so we're fronting
that cost
this is why i appreciate president trump
because he challenges the status quo and
ultimately he challenges us to think
differently you know president trump
brings a different thought process to
issues to where
you know look both the washington
establishment both republicans and
democrats over the years have become
sort of set in their ways we elected
president trump to disrupt that
and that's what he does yeah and and and
i think that that's why you know god
bless a lot of these generals and i
thank them for their service general
mattis is somebody that i admire
uh greatly but i don't understand why
the life of me why he went after
president trump the way that he did
i don't get it uh because you know just
because what the
president is proposing that we simply
think differently
that's all he's asking and and look
i i'm on board with let's get our men
and women home from afghanistan i told
you that i think that there's probably a
middle a safe middle ground yeah right
right i've articulated that but
i'm on board with it why because we've
done the same thing
for generations and i'm willing to try
something different
yeah i'm not i wouldn't go as hard as
there's a lot of people who say
get our troops out immediately it's on
america's place we shouldn't have been
in there in the first place
it's just not it's just not it's not the
world that we live in you know i mean i
mean maybe you can make that argument
for some place like germany
right but not afghanistan yeah yeah i
think
i mean look okay so here's a good
example of this tim look what happened
in iraq
when president obama pulled our troops
out before we were ready that gave rise
to isis that that leadership
vacuum we pulled out of that country
before strategically we were
ready right to leave and that created
isis and isis
rampaged across the middle east and look
well look what look what
uh president obama did to the middle
east they all they did was depose
autocrats you know from libya to syria
all over and all what did that do to the
middle east
it just sent the entire it was a powder
it's a powder keg over there and
and president trump by and large is is
dealing with that now now and
the reason why i'm saying all this is
look at how president obama left the
middle
east it was slavery yeah isis was at its
height of power the caliphate had
thousands of miles of geographic
territory they had physical bases
isis is utterly decimated okay
and there's a middle east peace deal
that was just broken
how often have you heard i mean i i
never thought that i'd see that in my
life
that's an unknown and they still came
after him for it what is it
this is this could be a precursor to
peace in the middle east
in our time and have you heard about it
on the news this should be
round-the-clock coverage for a month
but you don't hit enough think about it
think about how the middle east was
when when there was a transfer of power
from president obama to president trump
i mean in three short years this
president was able to negotiate a middle
east peace deal in which
other arab countries are now jumping on
board yep
why why do you want to know why i'll
give you a guess and i'll answer it for
you
uh do you know why because they all
oppose the iranian nuclear deal
yeah they all opposed empowering our
enemy i
you could look up op-eds i wrote about
this before i was even running for
political office the iranian nuclear
deal was an
absolute disaster it empowered the
number one state
sponsor of terror in the world and every
middle eastern country
hated it and so president trump because
he opposed that
and sought to broker peace deals between
israel and other arab countries look
we've got we are on we are on the
precipice of an historic peace agreement
in the middle east i'm telling you i
never thought i'd see it in my lifetime
but this president was able to do it and
so this is why i say
let's just work with the guy i mean my
god we don't always have to agree but
let's just work with the guy
could it be that peace is the problem
for them
to expand on expanding money to be made
in war
yeah i don't know i mean that's that's
like a that's like a you know the
military military-industrial complex is
that whole concept of beware the
military industrial complex
there's probably some wisdom to that i
think that we can you know from you know
with regards to looking at the pentagon
and figuring out ways that we can
tighten our belts there and spend more
efficiently there's a lot of fraud waste
and abuse at the pentagon especially
with contract procurement processes and
stuff like that we can do better
if you look at the the raptor what the
f-35 project that's a trillion dollar i
don't know i mean
don't quote me on the numbers there's
gonna be somebody out there
fact-checking me on the numbers after
this but it's it's
a it's a multi-billion dollar project
that could have been a lot cheaper it
could have been done a lot
a lot more for a lot less money in a
more efficient way
i think we can look at that but i i
personally i i i
am a big believer in peace through
strength what do you how do you feel
about like
what happened with libya no-fly zones
airstrikes
uh libya like you're talking about the
posing of qaddafi yeah
oh i thought we came we came we saw he
died i thought that was horrible
and now that and the libyan people will
tell you that as well
yeah i mean muammar gaddafi was a
terrible human being but he was somebody
that
was willing to work with the united
states of america
and sometimes look when you talk when
you're looking at diplomacy you know
you know when i was 24 years old leading
an infantry platoon in afghanistan i've
got a rifle across my lap and i'm
talking to somebody who i know is a
warlord
who i know a week from now is going to
be shooting at me
in some ditch might even kill me but i
got to work with them anyway
because guess what that's the world that
we live in i mean there's there's that
line from the avengers like we
we don't see the world as we want it to
be we see the world as it is
nick fury said it in a lot sexier way
than i did but it's the truth
right we deal with the world as it is
not a husband there we go we deal with
the world as it is not as
not as how we'd like it to be you know
and
i think no nobody had faith in president
this is what bothered me
president trump has consistently defied
the odds he's consistently
done things i mean look at look this
there has not been a president in our
white house that has been savaged as
badly as president trump
except president lincoln you know i know
he said it too
oh yeah you know what did he say that i
don't even know i'm not you're going to
have your people oh he's just parroting
trump talking points
i don't know what i mean i'm just saying
like it's but it's
the truth he's the most maligned man in
the white house yet he consistently
advances
he advances the agenda of freedom and
you know
i i i don't understand you know i don't
understand
why people aren't willing to give this
man a chance i i he
he's a fighter he cares about the people
it could be
social media induced derangement that
people have formed
extremist tribes they've polarized
there's no middle and trump must be bad
that's that's why that's why the theme
of my speech last night was trying to
bring people together trying to say
it doesn't matter where you come from it
doesn't matter
who you love it doesn't matter what
color your skin is
it doesn't matter your gender
stand with us fight for this country but
they think that's
racist they think you have to in fact
there's a quote from one of these
authors these these
you know great leftists i'm already
sexist
the next thing right next to the next
the next thing's going to be is shawn's
a racist you watch
there's a guy who straight up says the
only cure for past discrimination is
more discrimination
they they're absolutely saying they must
and so
when you you consider consider yourself
a conservative i'd imagine
yeah i'm conservative yeah i'm i'm i've
always when i was younger i was far left
you know i was anarcho punk
skateboarding rock i listened to punk
rock roanoke
and then i didn't turn out a radical
leftist well
you became a regular guy i suppose you
you like
look you get a job you pay taxes you
have a family or to understand why
things are the way they are
more importantly you know
you're all these things you're talking
about especially the the uh
afghanistan stuff because i've always
been very much like i think trump is
right to bring our troops out but you
made a really good point i hadn't
considered before
because i i haven't heard it uh straight
to my face
i've heard dan crenshaw talk about some
of this stuff and so i i certainly
respect
you know the people who've actually been
there to tell me here's what happens if
we just up and leave so
i i respect you're saying there's a
middle ground but what you've
experienced
is the world as it is as you were saying
right think about all of these stories i
don't know if you've seen these stories
where
young people are like i'm going to go
hiking in the hills of morocco and then
um yeah and they end up getting
kidnapped and and taken hostage
worse than that oh they're going to go
hiking through the iranian mountains or
something
like hostages it's trap i know it's
trash yeah and and so so
this i meant i remember this one story
where these people were riding their
bikes through tajikistan
and a nice vehicle pulled over like
yelling isis stuff i guess and just
lobbed their heads off right there i've
been around i've been around the world
not two places as dangerous as you've
been but i've been in many places i was
in egypt when the revolution happened
and i've seen what happens when there's
no stability and it's scary
i agree i was looking down from the
balcony of the hilton in egypt watching
people shoot at each other and i was
like i wonder if i'm gonna be able to
get out of this place
because i was there as a reporter i'm
watching the apc's roll through people
are screaming and cheering the fighting
broke up
we got out immediately and then they
shut all the bridges down i come back to
this country
and as somebody who grew up on the left
who was always complaining about america
and these these
unjust wars and ever and all this stuff
and i'm like man america imperialism i'm
all young
i i got older and so when i was when i
was in egypt stuff i wasn't that dumb
but when i was like you know 17 writing
music and stuff when i come back from
some of these countries
i remember walking up to uh you know the
immigration checkpoint
just one i can't remember exactly when
it was but i've been to a bunch of these
different countries
and the guy had to look into my passport
and he's like
it's like what are all these he's like a
bunch of arabic stuff and i started
laughing and i'm like i am so happy to
be back in america dude you have no idea
and he laughed and he's like all right
all right and he's like what are you
doing i'm a journalist and he's like i
hear you
and then i just like there's there's
kids they grew up in this country
they're in cities they go to colleges
they're pampered they're protected they
have no idea
they have no idea that we live in this
bubble it's like a walled city
united states where it's just we've got
our crime
we've got an increase in crime we've got
the lockdown we've got our problems but
man i i'm sure you could you could say
it better than i could well i mean
that's that's that's the that's the
double-edged sword of living in the best
country
in the most free society on the face of
the planet where
where we where if if we live in a free
society
right and generations of which have
lived in a free society
most of the time when you're a parent
and you've got kids your goal
once you have those kids if you're a
good mother or father is to say you know
what i just want to make sure that
the country that they han they inherit
is better than the one i have
and so every generation our country gets
a little better a little better
a little better and so we've got a lot
of people in this country
uh you know when you've got only point
four percent of the people who've served
who go out and defend freedom on a
day-to-day basis everybody else just
sort of
enjoys the trappings and blessings of
living in a free society
which can afford them views that are
inherently in some cases
the antithesis of being in a free
society yeah right
and um you know it's it's a conundrum
you know it's funny i i mention this
kind of often i i like to offer up to my
progressive friends
an opportunity to go anywhere in the
world it's a dream come true name one of
your causes that you're so
you know enthusiastic about and i will
see to it you get there and we'll get
you a good guide and
they're gone in two seconds because when
they you know i was talking to one guy
who was complaining about gaza
and israel stuff and i was like how
would you like to go there
wait what yeah how would you like to
have a flight because we can film it we
can make it a thing like your experience
you're this activist you talk about all
the time how would you like to be there
gone two seconds i got friends talking
like wait he go they go
in two seconds or they're like no no no
no no like they're they're just stop
talking just
conversation's over i'm not going there
are you crazy
i got i i have some i have this one
friend who's uh uh i've known for a
really long time
preaching up a storm about black lives
matter lives in chicago
i grew up in chicago they know what
chicago is like
and so i'm like this dude lives in the
suburbs i said i'll tell you what
i will hire you to produce a video i
want you to go i want you to i'm not
going to name the neighborhoods in
chicago i want to offend anybody but
they got some neighborhoods in chicago
man yeah you're not going to survive
i'm not even kidding there's there's
gang initiations where they literally
just kill random people
now if you're the wrong race walking in
one in in in a dangerous gang territory
you could find yourself seriously hurt
that's that's in america they call it
chiraq for a reason
i start talking to some of my friends
about all of their preaching and i said
would you like to go and do interviews
and they shut up immediately because
what bothers me the most about a lot of
these activists who preach all the stuff
the people i know in chicago know
exactly what chicago is like
there's rampant racism across the board
between all races there's gang violence
there's crime it is not some you know
it's not an oppressive patriarchy or
whatever the cops aren't going around
you know
going and like trying to just randomly
kill people
it's all like the penguin in batman
exactly exactly
look chicago's had its problem with with
corrupt government officials and police
sure yeah but you know this goes for the
cops everywhere in the country they're
not going out being like oh i hope today
i'm gonna kill somebody
like that's the last thing they want to
do it's scary no it's not true
and but there's these people like to
preach all this stuff i see these memes
they post like a tweet from somebody
saying like
the police are a death squad that goes
around hunting people down
and i'm like how'd you like to go to a
police department sit down and talk to
one of these guys go on they don't want
to do it
and i'm like that's not even dangerous
that's true let alone go to any of these
neighborhoods
they don't want to do it either like it
goes without saying that 99.9
of cops are good nobody dislikes bad
cops more than
good cops right and you go and talk to
these people and i i
love the police in my community you know
i i i support them because i know how
tough the job is man i mean you're
making split second life and death
decisions these people wake up every day
they put a gun on their hip a badge on
their chest and they don't know if
they're coming home
and i'm sorry there's something noble in
that yeah and
it's an imperfect job it's really
difficult
do they always make the right decisions
absolutely not but you know i i love and
appreciate the police and i talk to them
when i go to their departments and i
talk to them they will tell you that
you know some of the some of the worst
areas of crime in their communities they
like to go to the best because they want
those kids to have
a shot they care
and so i when i see this
this crazy defund the police stuff
it just makes me hurt for the police and
for the the communities that would be
affected by it it's just not right and
it's all in the service of what
a political agenda being pushed by the
democrats that's that's that's not
and by the way well joe biden doesn't
want to defund the police he just wants
to redirect their funding again a clever
manipulation i'm like like you know you
watch the
the interview with chris wallace and and
president trump and chris wallace is
pressing president trump as he should
journalists should suppress
political officials right but well joe
biden doesn't want to defund the police
then trump's like yes he does no he
doesn't he said he just wants to
redirect her funds and i'm thinking like
chris if i redirected funds from your
paycheck and gave it to another anchor
would you feel like you were
defunded this is really funny because
joe biden's running full speed as far
away from that as he as he can now
absolutely is
yes so at the time brookings the
brookings institute specifically said
what does defund the police mean it
doesn't mean abolishing the police it
just means reallocating funds to other
programs
so when joe biden was asked do you
support reallocating funds from police
to the program he goes yes
absolutely remember yes but now he's
like here's what's really funny i think
the fact checkers should clarify that he
he he backed off that very very quickly
and now
he's absolutely trying to be like i'm
gonna i'm gonna give him funding thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode